la législation au 21 avait prévu des
stocks si mes souvenirs sont bons
c'était quatre mois pour les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
et donc enfin c'était alors limité aux
produits qui avait fait l'objet de
pénurie
dans les deux ans précédant donc c'est
peut-être pas suffisant mais en tout cas
la démarche avait démarré à ce moment-là
pour essayer
je dirais de cadrer les stocks
nécessaires donc peut-être faut-il
élargir
cette disposition et je crois que enfin
nous participons à un comité
interministériel sur le sujet qui
cherche des solutions et en effet
déjà
l'authentification de quel médicament
lesquels enfin la constitution d'une
liste je dirais des médicaments
prioritaires pour lequel il serait
important d'avoir ces stocks va être
constitué
peut-être que alors il faut voir si
c'est les critères les modalités de
définition de ce qu'on appelle les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs est-ce qui permettent de couvrir
l'ensemble dont les dans la rupture
pourrait constituer une perte de chance
ça il faut vraiment ça mérite d'être
travaillé je crois que ça va l'être et
voilà nous participerons à ces travaux
ensuite
cette législation est-ce qu'elle est
appliquée déjà alors peut-être les
tentes mais est-ce qu'elle est appliquée
et là en effet bon c'est dur sort
peut-être d'inspection
et puis de pénalité le problème c'est
là c'est vraiment un peu personnel mais
c'est le problème c'est que les les
industries pharmaceutiques les
industriels sont des compagnies
mondiales maintenant multinationales
pour lequel le marché français n'est pas
un sujet
je veux dire nous représentons quand
même relativement peu de choses par
rapport à leur production mondiale et
donc il est pas certain que nos mesures
nationales et un impact important sur
sur leur stratégie mondiale et par
exemple
c'est pour ça que je disais pour les
prix pour l'augmentation des prix c'est
ça peut être une solution mais partielle
parce que évidemment j'imagine je ne
suis pas un industriel mais j'imagine
que centraliser complètement avoir
qu'une chaîne de production
représente des économies majeures pour
un industriel alors que le petit plus
qu'on va donner
voilà est-ce qu'il compensera voilà et
je dirais même quand on met des
pénalités si le gain de productivité
majeur que représente nos pénalités pour
un industriel il est possible aussi que
ce soit difficile
de se situer à ce niveau là voilà donc
je crois que en effet il y a la loi dit
qu'il faut des stocks il faut vérifier
que la liste de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majorit bien complète il
faut qu'elle couvre toutes les
situations délicates il faut faire
respecter cette loi par des inspections
après
qu'elle va être le résultat final voilà
c'est pas forcément évident
il faut pouvoir quand même ce sont des
maintenant les entreprises
pharmaceutiques sont des multinationales
qui ont des intérêts mondiaux et je
dirais de façon plus générale que c'est
pour ça que la réponse européenne est
importante parce que le marché européen
avec des systèmes de santé très
solidaires comme un qui prennent
beaucoup de choses en charge peuvent là
avoir un poids que nationalement nous ne
pouvons pas voir et c'est vrai c'est
vrai aussi pour pour les médicaments
innovants c'est pas vrai que pour les
médicaments anciens donc c'est pour ça
que là
l'Europe entière serait probablement
plus forte pour lutter
pour imposer un certain nombre de
contraintes que la France toute